[Music]
first of all social media is free so
that's the best thing that somebody
would have going for them is that their
their own marketing team
so if you start small and you figure out
what it is that you have to offer and
then go from there I think it's really
important what you say about social
media being free because if you've got
if you know if you know your product and
you know yourself and you know what you
can offer to people you can put that out
there on social media and grow a
community over time that can then
support whatever it is you're trying to
sell right well and you have your very
own focus group it's like a built-in
focus group of really testing ideas you
must have each one of us has various
things inside of us that we have as a
dream yeah or something we'd love to do
you know we just you have to really dig
deep figure out what that is and then if
you have a focus group like a social
media platform then you can sort of
figure out what's going to work for you
yeah I remember Kim on Twitter in the
early days yeah was choosing a color cap
for her fragrance right so she was also
choosing asking people what she should
wear to one of the awards ceremonies it
was something that she taught the rest
of us how to utilize social media in
figuring out you know how your community
responds to you who's following you and
then how to engage with those people and
have a relationship and that was
something that she she taught the rest
of us is when she did that first
fragrance and she said what color should
I do the bottle yeah I was shocked how
many people responded and then she
actually did the one that followed you
know what everybody voted for so I
thought that was really also gaining the
trust of the people that were following
her because they believed that she was
going to listen to them well I have a
very small intimate powerful Kick-Ass
just state-of-the-art team I'm so proud
of you guys and every everything that we
built together and I think that for me
one of the things that's been you can
probably answer this better than I
because you're you're the leader of the
team him at times but I think that for
me it's trusting one another and we have
longevity together we've been through so
much together which a lot of people that
are starting out don't have that yet
right but I think that you have to again
use your instincts it's about chemistry
and I think that when we're on the same
page and when you're on the same page as
your partners and your teammates that
that's everything being available to
people even though you have like you
have to be available you have to be
available you have to be dialed in you
have to be connected you have to know
what's going on all the time and you
have to be ready for whatever is thrown
your way yeah I mean every single day we
I feel like a fireman yeah you know
we're just putting out fires left and
right all of the time and I think that
with that attitude of anything is
possible that goes a long way I think
everybody has self-doubt from time to
time I mean I do you know
uh often think okay is this am I doing
the you know especially because I'm
everyone's manager and I don't want to
disappoint anybody and I'm a people
pleaser I really am as strong as I am
it's that soft you know there's another
side of me that just wants everybody to
be happy yeah everybody to be you know
in control of their day happy about the
decisions that we're making you know so
that's my self-doubt it's not actually
doubt it's just I'm a people pleaser I
think you have to have really tough skin
I mean anytime you enter the world of
social media you're opening yourself up
for criticism and it's just part of what
these platforms are subject to and I
think that you have to stay focused on
what you're doing stay focused on what
is happening and and what and what you
really want to communicate to the people
that are following you and not worry
about complete strangers that are
criticizing you and attacking you that
have never even met you
[Music]